so listen apparently the audio for the
second edition of youtube secrets leaked
out early and so i figured why not run
with it and i found out that you can
actually
get it for free if you have already
downloaded youtube secrets and so if you
didn't know um we are dropping the
second edition of youtube secrets you
can see this updated second edition
it has a whole two new chapters a whole
rewritten chapter new case studies all
kinds of stuff happening and we're going
to be rolling it out but is already out
and so um it didn't quite all get
synchronized i think the kindle's not
updated the physical book's not quite
ready but i figured hey why not turn
this into a party and just let you know
that if you um already have youtube
secrets
you can get this for free by just
updating your audible app and i'll
explain all the details in this video
but it's good to see if you're here live
what's up adam uh hit the like button
uh and uh let's dive straight into this
and i'll kind of tell you the details
plus i'd love to answer your questions
if you have a question drop three
question marks before and after your
question starm here in stream yard i'm
in an unsanctioned saturday afternoon
stream um i'm just solo uh a solo
edition out here today and so um
good to see you and uh my name is sean
cannell rhymes with youtube channel i'm
the author of youtube secrets along with
my friend benji and the second edition
is coming out and um i'm excited for
that and so let me give you all the
details um first
the brand new edition of youtube secrets
has
uh it's quite it's significantly larger
the original audiobook i think was about
three and a half hours this one's five
and a half hours and i'm excited it's
not fluff we really thought how do we
update this to a level that is just
insane you know the first book was
written in 2018 and we thought man
a lot's happened
we
had a hunch that youtube was gonna be
big um but it's far exceeded even our
wildest imagination
this next decade is going to be the best
decade on youtube and so
we really broke down the book rewrote it
but here's the cool thing i mean if you
if you if you'll need to get a second
edition physical copy it would be a
whole other book but the audiobook you
can get for free
and so all you gotta do
is um
go to your audible app on your phone
and uh
if you have the audible app let me know
if you already have youtube secrets
and go into your library and then what
you can do
is you go into your library and remove
from device
so if you remove it from device
assuming you've downloaded it right and
then you re-download it from the cloud
what'll end up happening
is you'll get the second edition for
free it'll just update and you'll get
the new preface uh the new introduction
as well as the new chapters including a
chapter on the perfect video recipe
including um a chapter on um
the new youtube features including
youtube shorts now if you don't have it
you of course you can also get it for
free if you don't have audible so if you
go to tubesecretsaudio.com
you can use you get one free credit just
by signing up to audible and you can get
it for free that way as well and then i
suppose if you do have audible and you
don't have the book then you also could
go the direction of just downloading it
with one of your credits
um and so uh let me uh got some good
questions coming in scott says is there
any difference in your basic strategy in
the book that's a great question
the original
seven seas of youtube success remain the
same scott
and that's kind of cool when we created
this book
we wanted it to be timeless and we
learned that the framework we created
was timeless so here's the seven seas of
youtube success number one courage
number two
clarity number three channel number four
content number five community number six
cash number seven consistency i'm
impressed that i was able to do that off
the top of my head um and so
the seven seas of youtube success it
starts with courage you gotta punch fear
in the face it then goes deeper in
clarity in terms of you gotta get clear
on your niche we've updated that chapter
with some new details to give you some
more clarity so actually really the
introduction of the book and this is the
first edition
not the introduction the book's broken
into two parts part one is the seven
seas
that is mainly unchanged because we've
learned we created an unbreakable
framework that will actually transcend
time you always got to be courageous
even if you feel comfortable now there's
a new level of courage you always got to
pursue higher levels of clarity you
always gotta refine your channel
strategy you always gotta
double down on the quality of your
content you always wanna engage your
community and give back to your
community you always gotta figure out
new ways to make cash there's so many
opportunities to make cash now too
in this new era on the creator economy i
mean whether it's new affiliate programs
whether it's youtube adding features
i mean i don't think super chat and
things like that were out back when we
first created this book or channel
memberships for that matter because we
wrote this book in 2018. so there's
there's new there's things like kofi
right you know things like patreon buy
me a coffee new ways to monetize um and
then consistency but really part two is
where it gets interesting and my
favorite chapter in the book is called
the perfect video recipe and the second
edition of the book and so um there's
that's there we also rewrote the social
media chapter with a whole different
perspective
um that is pretty timely and it actually
kind of is along the premise
of social media has a lot of negatives
to it meaning
it can really actually be a distraction
from your goals from youtube success if
you spread yourself too thin too soon so
we really have another level of strategy
on the social media part
and then there's a whole new chapter
called new youtube features and we go
through shorts community tab youtube
stories we double down on live which
isn't technically new but there's it's
it's been completely revamped really and
so anyways um definitely you know check
it out scott uh we'll let you know when
the physical books
are in second edition i don't think
that's why this is kind of a leak is the
audiobook uh it didn't really come out
synchronized and so hey it's cool that
the audio is out if you want to grab it
this is kind of cool this is the korean
translation of youtube secrets i think
the book's been translated into um eight
uh different languages now and so uh if
you just downloaded it thank you so much
oh by the way too i figured why not um
do something cool and if you
have
read
uh
youtube secrets or you grab the second
edition and actually i would love it if
you grab the second edition and you do a
review i want to hook you up with
something cool um and so
um i want to this is kind of an uh an
unreleased
it's actually kind of been a sunsetted
course but it's super valuable it's
called crush collabs
and um 97
youtube course i'd love to send this to
you for free if you just do a review so
if you email support seance.com with the
subject line book review
and then just post a link or a
screenshot to your review meaning your
review has to be legit
on amazon
and um
i think if you you know go to the
reviews
uh like you come in here and a
screenshot could be like
you use a screenshot tool like uh you
know grab the screenshot of of your name
you know and then just email that to me
i'd love to hook you up with this maybe
you've left a review in the past i just
would appreciate it it really helps
authors
when you do book reviews so if you want
me to send you this course crush collabs
is all about collaborations how do you
reach out to people to collab how do you
collab with people if you don't have to
meet in person what are the best ways to
do it digitally
how do you
reach out to get people to be
interviewed on your show
and what are even some of our scripts
and emails hook you up with that for
free you can't even buy this course but
if you would want me to send this to you
do a review by the way sometimes when
you do a review it takes a day or two
for it to even show up on amazon so if
you get your review done
and and by the way if you you can do any
kind of review or maybe you did one in
the past but if you specifically do a
review of the second edition that's what
i'd be looking for the most like i'm so
pumped especially here's my here's my
ask of you if i've ever added value to
your life
one if you already have the audiobook
two
re-download it right as i've described
for free and then if you haven't left a
review three leave a review and be like
this is so cool i got the second edition
for free and oh my gosh it's it's great
now by the way i'm not telling you
what you should say in the review even
if you were like the book sucks that's
great too i'll still send you the course
uh for crush collabs so of course leave
an honest review um but uh if you do
find out that it's as good as i think it
is then i'd love to hook you up with
this um as as well so um if you have any
questions post question marks before and
after your question um and uh i'll star
a couple of those
and uh let me know where you're watching
from i'm out here in las vegas it's 1 14
p.m about to uh head out with my wife
and
uh kids uh kids kid i have a son named
sean bradley i have a um
second son coming in september 3rd so
that's that's cool
and uh i'm starring some of your
questions right here smash like if
you're fired up for a new day
and um
we will be
answering some of your questions
here in just a second
let me see where you're shouting out
from though shout me out texas in the
house we got norfolk va we got uh
pennsylvania in the house we got st
augustine
uh we got it's 9 p.m in the uk the
gaming mum always good to see you
phoenix arizona in the house nashville
in the house lindsay good to see you uh
saw you on instagram live as well i did
see over there i appreciate you
nashville is a vibe man i love nashville
my friend john mariana is out there with
like this nft nashville like that's a
whole scene
now it seems like i hear people going
out to that my friend rory vaden lives
out in nashville my friend john acuff
lives out in nashville
um bra fam in the house good to see you
okay so let's answer some questions hong
kong 4 15 a.m
man thanks so much for being here i
appreciate you being here
and um
thank you uh thanks for being here okay
so if you got a question for question
marks before and after i see you san
diego
let's answer some of your questions can
you get uh v2 uh as a physical book yeah
so the second edition of the book
should be out shortly um if you actually
go to amazon you may see this new cover
which has this yellow strip that's how
you know
um but there's kind of a process
involved in getting the listing updated
so just know that it's coming of course
we will definitely make a very targeted
announcement when that is clear what i
can say for a fact is that the audio has
leaked ahead of the physical book so
tubesecretsaudio.com
will allow you to get that
off of audible if you want to check that
out how much does keyword order matter i
use vidiq and i can move keywords around
when they tell me it's the top keyword
adam pretty minimally
um
uh let me break down though some keyword
order or some optimization order here's
what matters in optimization adam
uh number one the title by a landslide
like
the title
carries
the most weight
when it comes to keywords so let's check
out this new video from omar new adobe
premiere features
so
for example
adobe premiere pro is a keyword
and that matters a great deal
uh in the title of course
uh and new
you know adobe the new adobe premiere
export settings captions and more this
is all searchable because if there's new
features to adobe premiere
and then the front loaded
uh sentence of the description now
carries the most weight now this is not
going to make or break your video your
video itself is going to make or break
the video the content
audience retention
but
the title carries the weight
then
the beginning of the description
and then as far as the tags go it would
be the first tag or the second tag
but
tags carry a lot like lot less weight
than they used to and
this video even in like uh if we were to
judge it in ranking this is more of like
a utility-based video it's just kind of
we shot it at nab some new announcements
of course if you want to win for
something you want to put out a really
good effort
of
um adobe
adobe premiere pro
really understanding
like uh for beginners
like a strong video like this right
and then
really this is a good one from vince
opera right here
premiere pro tutorial for beginners
2022. you're getting the 2022 in there
you're getting the word tutorial in
there you're getting the word beginners
there like that's what matters good
thumbnail click through rate and then i
would imagine he follows up with a good
video here's one of our ranked videos
right omar's videos ranked number two
here two years old one million views
adobe premiere tutorial followed up with
a good video
great thumbnail
stands out on the page
so
um
keyword order is not a huge deal i do
love vidiq where it obviously allows you
to like quickly go plus plus plus like
get your title right and add the
keywords in because i want to do the
best practices but my strategy around
keywords is about a three-minute task
using vid iq like just you know figuring
out the big idea and then just adding
using the little plus button and then
moving on spend most of your attention
adam
on
title content thumbnail
all right uh any thoughts on shorts on
your regular channel as opposed to
separate channel
and what easy video editor do you
recommend for
pc so adam
number one
i would say
if your shorts
whether it's a short video
a medium length video a medium to long
video a long live stream video ask
yourself this question adam
why did the viewer subscribe and what
value do they hope to get from the
channel
if the short is going to deliver that
value
then in a way there's no reason it
should be on a separate channel
but if the short is off brand
the word i like is promise if the short
is off promise
so we're posting seven videos a week now
on our think media channel
five full length videos two shorts
more or less monday through friday
full length videos saturday and sunday
two shorts
it's also an experiment which by the way
everything should be an experiment right
you should always be testing analyzing
the data and then making adjustments and
course correcting as you go
but
the key
is we are asking ourselves this question
because i'm making a lot of
vertical video
and just because a vertical video for
example can work over on my instagram
let's say
um just because a vertical video works
over here
any of these theoretically could be
uploaded to think media as a short right
these are these are like this could be
actually uploaded as a short
but this is actually like a blatant
promo that patrick bet david is speaking
at in in vegas so while i could do it
i'm not going to upload this on think
media
right
and then there's also some things like
maybe
like
like this one
like this gets a little personal
developmenty
which is fine because i kind of i go
there i like to go there my my instagram
account is called sean cannell it's my
account now of course i want to mainly
talk about youtube but i get a little
bit
more personal development so here's my
point that i'm thinking
is we are asking ourselves
is this on brand or on promise for think
media is it close enough and here's how
i define that
is it talking about content creation is
it talking about youtube is it directly
about cameras is it directly about how
to do video creation
if it gets if it's too far outside of
that scope
won't post it there
so that's it i think that you should
experiment with shorts on your regular
channel
so long as about to sneeze one two
where's the mute button
perfect um
so long as
it's on brand for the channel and it
honors the reason people subscribed uh
that they subscribe for if it doesn't
then absolutely post it maybe on another
channel or consider not doing it at all
because it's hard enough to grow one
channel and try to build everything up
try to focus all your energy and your
effort and build everything up
easy video editor for pc i think filmora
is easy some people da vinci has a free
level
some people think da vinci is easy i
don't know if it'd be easy um
and
yeah that's i think filmora might be if
in fact i'd like to ask anybody watching
we've got 99 people on uh let me know if
anybody has a recommendation for an easy
video editor for pc
i like adobe premiere personally but
that
is not easy quote unquote
if you didn't hear uh youtube secrets
audio edition leaked out a little bit
earlier than we intended on audible so
if you want to check out the updated
second edition of our book youtube
secrets on audible go to
tubesecretsaudio.com
and um
let me know if you have any questions
about that
uh
yep filmora i've heard premiere elements
is a great one to check out uh that's a
lighter premiere and i i think you can
get it a lot of times for like 80 bucks
you can get adobe photoshop elements and
adobe premiere elements as a combo
for a good deal oftentimes and it's not
even reoccurring
meaning
you pay once
ob premier
elements 2022.
so here's the bundle
photoshop elements premiere elements
80 bucks
amazon.com
uh there it is
there it is eighty dollars you get both
and uh this is the student and teacher
edition which technically you need to be
a student or teacher um
and stop
proof of eligibility
oh yeah so you you need to actually
prove that in order to get this version
otherwise
you know grab a different version but
yeah adobe premiere elements photoshop
elements i agree adobe rush is worth
looking at and adobe rush
is also a mobile solution
quick turnarounds quick edits
uh youth man's used davinci
um you know
if you haven't heard billy
uh ribca
um
is actually he's on the think media team
now he is our executive producer
uh for uh kind of helping us with
content and whatnot and you can check
out his channel
uh he is the da vinci expert all things
da vinci how to install davinci davinci
18 modern titles in da vinci ultimate
glitch effects in davinci video editing
da vinci
so billy's the man and uh
you could check out his channel if
you're a da vinci
uh addict and he's a part of the think
media collective the think media team
now
uh hey thanks for the super chat really
appreciate it hey uh you're welcome
thanks so much for the love and
uh let me know how the update goes
because i'm assuming you already have
the audiobook and therefore you can just
up delete
remove from device
and then update
re-download it and you'll get the second
edition it leaked out early so if you
want to you know grab the new edition
worth your time too we really put
uh this is a fresh take on dominating
youtube
for a whole new decade updated second
edition
uh thanks for the love
and um
if you got a question post four question
marks before and after your question
and
uh i will star some of those
power director
old classic
sony vegas
great i used to use sony vegas back in
the day shot cut
marcus good to see you in the house
appreciate you
um
yes
no need for the annual subscription or
even the monthly subscription when you
use elements you can just pay once and
just keep using it
good to go on there all right we got a
question coming in
should i remove videos from my channel
that are not on brand but have done well
yes and here's why
let's dig into the think media
analytics to see
what we can learn to illustrate an
answer to your question
in fact we have some videos that
admittedly
here's the question
are the videos
bringing you the wrong subscribers
okay
so what you want to do
is you want to go into your real-time
analytics
because you're saying the videos
if they've done well but they stopped
getting views it might not be a big deal
but here's the big key if they've done
well
uh but they are
still getting views
but they're attracting potentially the
wrong subscribers
and and here's ones that are kind of a
ironic are sort of ironic for think
media and you know just to illustrate
so two of our best videos this one right
here is an ad for our event growth video
live in las vegas
which is a few days away by the way if
you haven't um heard are you coming to
grow a video live it's going to be
insane we're about 75 we're almost sold
out um but
this video right here
not only came out in 2021 but it gets 20
000 views every two days
now downloading sound effects royalty
free right in meme effects for video
editing
it's not completely off brand for our
channel
however if you want funny sound effects
for your video and here's here's the
even better thing to look at is you want
to
dive into the data
and you ask yourself
okay is this attracting the right
audience
and
you know
one where's audience coming from us fine
it is interesting the audience is a
little bit younger 18 to 24 funny sound
effects predominantly male all good
and and by the way i am completely
comfortable leaving this video up
but i would say
and it's it's it's
it is attracting a ton of subscribers
i don't know about a ton let's actually
look but i mean tens of thousands so far
and then you just gotta ask yourself are
they the right
subscribers
and my conclusion is it's all good well
maybe not a ton so seven thousand six
six point nine
um
but
those individuals here's here's let's
think about it deeper why did they
subscribe
they wanted free sound effects
we don't do that very often we did the
meme one later
and uh
and so then we did that one but of
course it would be this would be a
better example this would it'd be much
better if they subscribe for
how to title a youtube video that'd be
like exactly what we want or the new
adobe premiere settings because we teach
video editing
so that's the answer to your question
if those videos are still attracting
subscribers
but those subscribers would not be
interested in what your channel is doing
right now you should make those videos
private or unlisted you should shut them
down
because
they're ultimately not going to help you
achieve what you ultimately want to
achieve and
an example would be
if maybe i experimented a little bit
with gardening
and i made a video
on
how to do a raised planter and grow
healthy tomatoes and if that video
was still getting views and subscribers
and
attracting a bunch of people that were
like wow this guy's gardening
information is amazing
but i went the direction i'm going now
with think media and here's one way one
thing you can look at as well you could
go
in the last
28 days
so 712 new subscribers came from this
video so if you have a video
that is bringing you new subscribers
but you're no longer making that content
you're actually going to confuse the
algorithm
and and you're not going to get closer
to your ultimate goal even though
it's it's going to hurt a little bit
because
we love vanity metrics
oh but my numbers are going higher oh
but i'm closer to a thousand subs oh but
i'm closer to a hundred thousand
okay
and yeah you can maybe get a silver play
button or a gold play button
but what's it really matter if it's just
a mixed bag of really the wrong focused
audience
you have to think deeply not all metrics
are good metrics not all views are good
views not all subscribers are good
subscribers
so i would i would think clearly about
what the vision of your channel is the
goal of your channel is who your
channel's for why people should
subscribe
and uh
and double down on that
okay
if you got a question put four or five
question marks before after your
question
um
and i'll answer i got a bunch of good
questions coming in here smash like if
you're grateful to be alive today
and
quick update
i'm doing this stream as a reaction to
discovering that youtube secrets
second edition is now out on audible a
little bit ahead of when we attended but
people are finding out they can get it
for free if you've already downloaded
the audiobook
you can just update it inside of your
audible app and you can grab the second
edition for free worth your time a lot
of new content about two hours of new
content on the audible edition physical
coming soon enough and
if you want to really leave a review of
any youtube secrets i mean you've read
it before whatever the by by reviewing
the second edition or whatever because
it'll ultimately be the same listing
it's only better it's this stronger it's
this a lot stronger right this is the
first edition
here's the korean edition
um and
if you want our course crush collabs for
free um all about how to do
collaborations reach out for
collaborations get a channel that's
bigger to you to collaborate with you
get guests that are out of your league
on your interview show
you want some emails that we wrote just
email support seancano.com after you've
left a review and that review is clearly
public on amazon either audible or the
main site just put in the subject line
book review and then
put a screenshot or a link to your
review just so we could verify it on the
think media team
that'll be starting
uh
uh we'll be getting back to you by the
way i'm streaming on the weekend
by business days next week so just be a
little patient but we will totally honor
this a 97 value this is like a i think a
couple hour course that we recorded a
little while ago with omar we've done a
lot of collabs as you know i've
interviewed
uh
hundreds now of different youtube
influencers and along with benji who's
the co-author of the book um we've had
we've gotten in touch with all kinds of
crazy people casey neistat has been on
the show
gary vaynerchuk's been on the show
um
as well as have continued to be grant
cardone lewis house
and so um if you're interested in just
getting that for free
um it's actually pretty chill you know
we'll just send that to you if you just
leave a review of the book and email
a screenshot or a link to your
your review at support seancano.com with
the subject line book review and we'll
hook you up with this online course for
free why not and we're super pumped for
the second edition of this book believe
that it's updated
for a new decade it's four years later
since the first edition came out number
one best-selling youtube strategy book
in the world over 80 000 copies sold
which is pretty gnarly
but the future is forward youtube is
alive and well it's not declining it's
actually increasing
more monthly active users more watch
time um is competition increasing yes
but so is consumption so if you got your
strategies right you got your focus
right
there's also
is competition increasing sure but
there's also just more
interest
in like for example things that never
existed before
like the metaverse wasn't a thing now it
is nfts weren't a thing now they are
crypto wasn't a thing now it is
uh peloton wasn't a thing now it is
so there's always new opportunities and
youtube is the town square of video on
the internet by a landslide now it's
time to double down on your strategy now
it's time to go all in
and uh
this book's here to help you
and you know if you don't have an
audible account there's two different
ways you can get this free so
tubesecretsaudio.com
and free is a good deal in my opinion um
you might disagree uh so
can we get the free book if we have the
printed book
no unfor unfortunately if you have the
printed book then no but if do you have
an audible account because if you don't
have an audible account just go to
tubesecretsaudio.com and you actually
can use they'll give you one free credit
so
yes
if you already have used that credit
then then you'll have to use an audible
credit for it worth it though
did you know you also can return your
audible credits i mean i don't know if
they like you do it a lot but you
actually can be like i don't like this
and they'll let you exchange it and
stuff it's pretty cool
so um
don't just take my word for it actually
check out the book find out that it's
great
and
let's keep it moving all right hey
talking about books when's heather's
book youtube made simple coming out
youtube made simple is coming out first
quarter 2023
excited about it
all right did you remove youtube empire
from your courses i can't access it
despite its purchase
um no uh you absolutely should be able
to access it
if it was inside of your members area
but it's no longer there we'd be happy
to fix that just email us at uh
you know what you know what a really
good url to go to is
you can do a support ticket at
thinkmediasupport.com
i'd recommend going
and we'd be happy to help you
uh there you go please fill out this
form great so i don't know where that
question came from but i'm posting think
media support
in
i'm on stream yard so it's only going to
go to like the youtube stream where this
is
and the facebook stream
think or just go to
oh
thinkmediasupport.com
hook we'll we'll get you sorted
craig i appreciate you craig thanks for
being here releasing two videos on the
same day how much time should you place
between them i i like okay so
i like to place time between them
as much as possible
so
a lot of times if we
do a live stream on think media
we will we might also release a video on
think media so here's what our schedule
would be schedule upload 5 am our local
time
you can always check inside of your
analytics to see the best time to upload
that's what we do so new think media
video comes out 5 a.m pacific standard
time
now if there's a live stream that'll
also be scheduled in stream yard where
we are hanging out right now
and maybe that's scheduled for 10 am so
about five hours later but it might be
scheduled for nine so
i wouldn't actually overthink it too
much i would just generally try and
separate them
and if you're going to release two
videos the other way we'll do that is
shorts we might release a short
and a video in the same day yeah try to
separate them by a couple of hours don't
worry about it too much but i would try
to give it four five six hours if
possible or morning and night a video
drops at five a.m
and you go live at night at four to five
or six or something
um if possible i delay by one day
like all things being equal
if you have sev like for example on
think media we have seven units each
week
five regular videos two shorts
um
that's our chosen
content calendar and upload schedule
and so
we are doing it one a day
as opposed to
two on some days and some days none if
that makes sense so i mean assuming you
have that many up units to upload
and what we love craig is the schedule
upload feature on youtube
so
a lot of times videos are scheduled
i mean the weekend videos are scheduled
before the week ends
in fact our new strategy
we're testing and we'll be happy to
report back is we're uploading shorts
on saturday and sunday
and uh
we scheduled like
eight
months
eight shorts
which is two months so we schedule like
two months ahead saturday and sunday
two
a week
times four is eight
okay that's only one month
so a month ahead so we we scheduled
eight shorts
two saturday and sunday for an entire
month all at once like obviously you had
to like download them and title them and
got them all optimized and so there you
go so like on autopilot those are just
come out in fact i'm i forgot we're even
doing it i'll all looking like oh yeah
we uploaded a new video today and then
i'll go in the comments and engage and
do all that stuff as well so
those are a few tips for you hey smash
like if you're just joining uh let me
know where you're joining from in the
world my name is sean cannell rhymes
with youtube channel uh i am announcing
here we're streaming a couple places if
you're part of the vra fam drop a
hashtag vrafam
i just wanted to get the news to you
because it hit my radar
that um
even though it wasn't quite i planned it
that the updated second edition of
youtube secrets is out and you can get
it for free so i want to thank you so
much for the support of the book
if you've already listened to it
downloaded it on audible all you got to
do is remove it from your library
redownload it and boom the new one will
be in your in your library good
refresher but also
um about
two hours of new content and the whole
thing has been re-recorded redone
because we rewrote it updated case
studies uh very
strong project to get your mind right
your strategies right the seven seas of
youtube success have not changed
um but there's a new chapter on how to
use social media to grow your channel a
new chapter on the perfect video recipe
it is an enlightened approach to how the
youtube algorithm really works
and and there was a lot of outdated
things that are deleted like we took out
uh the approach to ranking is different
now you know as the creator of video
ranking academy that course first came
out
at uh in 2016 at the beginning of 2016.
that's six years ago like things have
changed and youtube secrets came out in
2018 it's 2020. now of course ctr abd
um of course uh the engagement signals
being on video signals much more than
you know any kind of
tags or anything really extra optimizing
your video and so the book has those
types of insights as well as uh it'll
just be great and i think encouraging to
you
um as well and so christianity explained
is in the house i created the same
content for blog podcasts and youtube
right now i'm liking both on blog
should the youtube video be separate
from the blog same content you know
what's kind of cool about that question
is um i think you can get away i think
people underestimate how much of the
same content they can use
i think
that
one of the reasons why you might be
getting burned out or exhausted is
because you're constantly trying to say
new things
i also think that if you're constantly
trying to say new things the things
you're saying can't be that strong
because what's kind of true about
truth and really solid
wisdom or answers or advice
is that
the tried and true is usually what works
so if you're constantly trying to come
up with new things it'll probably be a
pressure that will push you to
share untested theories or share things
that are half-baked or put you into an
unsustainable pace
so
what i would recommend
is
that you say
the same things
in
new ways
to new people
that's the formula
you want to be saying
you want to figure out kind of what your
core message is so i'm assuming you're
doing like bible study right or you're
teaching things around faith and
christianity great right
again it's not like if someone wants to
come up to you and they're like i have a
new doctrine
the apostle paul would warn okay that's
where you know we're not looking for
some like something new here we're
looking for the same gospel right now of
course though
there should be modern illustrations
which would be saying the same thing in
a new way saying the same thing more
creatively
so if someone follows me for a while and
you probably recognize this you're part
of our community like sometimes people
be like
sean says the same thing it'd be like
yeah because i'm going to share what
works
like
you know i want to share michael jordan
says master the fundamentals and
everything else you do will rise
so why are we trying to master the
non-fundamentals when the fundamentals
are the foundation of ultimate success
okay that was a long road around the
mountain to get to the point to say
when you say the same thing in new ways
a lot of times that's you saying the
same thing
in a blog though which might be writing
out your thoughts
saying the same thing
long form in a podcast watch saying the
same thing
by turning them into tick tocks and
short form videos
so
for example like as i'm doing these
types of videos right here if you've
seen any of these
i'm actually
using like i actually taught this in a
blo in a podcast
i i had a podcast that was all about
complaining making excuses over thinking
and comparing
and that podcast was like 35 minutes of
me going off on these four things
that you should stop doing
so all i did was i dug up my podcast
notes
and then
refined it down
and shared the same content in the
podcast in less than 60 seconds
and turned it into an instagram reel
and eventually this will be a youtube
short
so
the punch line being is i mean it was
hard work to sit down and like plan out
an outline for my video podcast
so then i can just go look at the long
form version and be like all right let
me share that as less than 60 seconds
turn the camera sideways did it as a
vertical video
so my encouragement to you today and i
hope this is actually really helpful for
you on a saturday or whenever you're
watching this replay
is
um
don't be afraid
to to look at
your past videos if you use google docs
or whatever note-taking software if you
have any content outlined if you even if
you have um
if you ever wrote a book or an e-book or
you're sitting on you have a journal and
you've got a lot of stuff that like you
feel like you've shared before
you're sitting on gold
if you've been a content creator
for 12 24 36 months you should be
resharing remixing and repurposing
so much of your stuff as opposed to
trying to go find new stuff
and here's what makes it new
what makes it new
is though
having a fresh take on it what makes it
new is
contextualizing it to a new year it's
2022.
what makes it new is
youtube secret second edition is
new but it's also the same
so it's still the seven seas of youtube
success but it's all new stats it's all
new case studies
there are a few new changes and we have
the chapter but we also this is actually
kind of a great example if we're kind of
a meta case study obviously as i'm
letting you know about this book is out
but i also see a lot of people they want
to go write a new book
like in the author space
why don't you put out why don't you keep
promoting the same book
i heard dean graziosi say that once
i think um one of his books hit a
hundred thousand copies and his team
came to him and they said dean
your book just hit a hundred thousand
copies congratulations
and they go
so what's the next book gonna be
now that you know we should celebrate
and then like what's your next book and
he goes next book why don't we keep
promoting this book
sold 100 000 copies why don't we do 200
000 like and and and i think too often
because you're always trying to say new
things
no no say the same things in new ways to
new people or say the same things in the
same way watch to new people
because if one person in your comments
is like you're saying the same thing i
get 30 000 subscribers on think media
every month
so if you've heard it before great
skip the video i'm talking to new people
and you got to figure out how to do that
too so constantly be thinking that's why
as you grow your business and brand how
do i expand this thing out
by maybe hiring somebody or using
repurposedhouse.com
to to expand out into other mediums
vertical video tick tock
linkedin articles other places and how
do i also create strategic content that
helps me reach a new audience
because eventually too if your current
audience is not resonating your current
fa like you need new people you just do
like
if your current audience in a way hasn't
taken action
like they probably won't so you
everybody needs to be reaching new
people like any business owner needs to
be reaching new customers yes going
deeper with customers you have finding
ways to keep serving the customers that
you have but you got to be reaching new
people right it's i mean it's expand
grow be fruitful and multiply
all right
beat that one to uh
a pulp
um okay how we doing
uh
hit the like button thanks for being
here and
uh
let's start a few questions to get them
queued up
and thank you for hanging out with me on
a saturday
and uh let's see
oh this is a good question how likely is
it that the kindle version will update
it that's the same thing will happen
i'm across my fingers i believe the
gaming mum that when the kindle version
of youtube secrets
is
updated
you will get it for free as well
so let's if you go to the amazon listing
right now
what you can see
is uh
you can see that
a paperback says it's this updated
second edition but what oh let me see
here too
ooh
maybe you can actually order the
physical because if you go inside it
gives you a preview of what's inside
oh my gosh
here's the new chapters
okay so you got the perfect video recipe
brand new chapter the social media the
good the bad and the ugly completely
rewritten chapter
discoverability
is uh
completely rewritten because of the way
ranking works being different
um collaborations
similar uh temples team think different
new youtube features
and then the appendix is completely
rebuilt with
um
all kinds of new resources it's a lot's
kind of happened so excited about it
plus a new preface and whatever else
so apparent well wait a minute let's
check all kindle
see
so old kindle is the old one
and this is where we're at this is why
i'm on here
uh like it leaked it's we don't know
there's the old in fact the old
book it apparently is 197 pages let me
verify that
yeah this is 192 this physical copy of
the first edition
so i'm about to order this because i
don't even have a second edition right
now
so this one is 272 pages
i'm about to amazon prime myself my book
because i don't have a copy
uh let's see monday may 9th great here
for it
so it looks like you can get the
physical
i'll make sure that's linked up in the
description if you happen to be watching
the replay and that's kind of neat
and it looks like the kindle is not
updated
so whatever but i the same should be
true that once the kindle is updated
um you could just remove it from your
device redownload it and you'll get the
second edition for free unfortunately
obviously the physical edition you'll
have to rebuy the second edition because
it's a physical book and obviously
there's no way i could if i could like
doctor strange
and like literally you came you're like
oh my gosh like the book literally
teleported and transmuted itself into
the second edition that'd be pretty cool
but i can't do that but these digital
versions
you're literally getting hooked up with
the updates for free if you already got
either the audiobook or the kindle
so that's kind of cool
and uh
that's that's good news i'm about to
order the physical second edition
we discovered that together
this is the height of luxury anybody
know that movie anybody know that quote
we'll see if anybody could call that one
out
um all right
let's see let's see
yeah so
in season ministries with randy just
resubscribed to audible and downloaded
the second edition oh cool great i
appreciate it thanks for grabbing the
book
um
all right lightning round is there such
a thing with me i don't know if there is
but i'm gonna go for it uh lightning
round okay i'm beginning to expand my
brand and i'm hosting my first ever
event for home theater
two channel music enthusiasts in july
any advice for hosting your first event
come on
youth man lightning round
um
i can't go lightning round on that but
i'll i'll give you some advice i love
the question
um
it's harder than you think to do
in-person events it's like very diff
most people underestimate how hard it's
going to get to be some to get someone
to come out even if it's free
uh especially in today's world it's just
like people don't have to travel there's
virtual events there's pandemics there's
like people are worried about traveling
so
so don't underestimate the amount of
effort and
marketing energy that you should put
into it
don't
underestimate the fact that people will
buy tickets and not come or they will
register and not show up
so the level of energy you just kind of
want to 10x the amount of energy you
think it's going to take
and the amount of touch points and
follow-up you'll want to do to enroll
the people who've even said they're
going to come to actually come
if possible like if it was
you know call everyone and be like i'm
so excited that you're coming
and um heads up here's some details that
you need to know and you're like well
that's a lot of work yeah events are are
a lot of work and and
it's powerful though to potentially you
know if you could have someone help that
just follows up or texts texts or calls
calls everyone that's potentially uh
coming
um
as far as when it also comes to your
first event
you've probably been to events but i
don't know how much long okay it's in
july uh
attend a couple events or meetups and
you've probably been doing this
but look with a whole new set of eyes
about
things that about distinctions
that you would want to change for your
event so here's 56 things that i start
to notice and then i think about when
applying to events
walk i walk into event
why is there a trash can i was just at
an event called the ultra converts in
vegas why is there trash cans
and like
sewage
standing where we're being forced to be
in line like could we have moved those
because i'm an event person myself okay
get inside why is the tablecloth all
sketchy and there's a weird box of
t-shirts and it looks like this place is
trashed okay great
why is there a completely inefficient
point of registration here
that we just skipped by that doesn't
really make sense why did they not
pre-communicate with me about
registration and how that was supposed
to happen
this is a huge bottleneck this is like
the theory of constraints just what are
all the bottlenecks okay get into the
event
troubleshoot your audio ahead of time
now you're an audio you have no gr you
have zero grades for this your audio
needs to be perfect
you are an audio person
and that's you know how hard audio can
be
please have your lighting be right
please have the stage clean please have
no feedback please have the mics work
we went to an event in la big youtube
event
and
it's funny too because it's literally a
content creator conference but i've
never seen such bad audio and video it's
actually kind of historic and what they
would do is they would hand the mic
the person it would cut in and out
probably because it was wi-fi
microphones and uh not like a better
frequency i guess that's what i'm
thinking because there's too many
uh gigahertz you know conflicting and so
uh
it would be like
and it cut and what they would do is
then they would come up and the audio
person would just hand them a different
one
and then that one would suck and then
the audio person they would just keep
like switching mics and it was never
solving the problem so
don't cheap out in audio video lighting
um and
i remember one time i was at an event
that casey neistat was speaking
and
he had videos to play
at a youtube conference
like he was gonna play his videos
like bike lanes
and like
uh some of his original viral videos
and he had his laptop
and i remember like four avl guys
gathered around his podium as casey
neistat is keynoting at your event
and they were all like
they're like plugging in
dongles and things
and and they never were able to get the
videos to play
at a youtube conference so you would
think
that like audio video and lighting is
easy but it's not apparently
and so things like these are kind of my
pet peeves as just thinking about
parking lot to platform
uh
thinking about
the experience you know i think about
the music playing in the too many events
like
opening night networking party i go to
dallas
i'm at an event
these are all these people too these are
content creators now maybe they're not
event promoters and creators but dude
you gotta know that music creates energy
it sets the mood it sets the tone it
sets the atmosphere
and like
nice place
a little cash bar
and i'm up here like we couldn't put a
little ambiance like could it have a a
little music plan
like
energy atmosphere what's the vibe how
does it feel odor
like sometimes you know you do an event
at
uh a
um
gym
like put
get some potpourri you know like
actually think about making
the
making the place smell good like that's
all
the five senses that people are going to
experience from parking lot to platform
we take our events seriously man i'm
excited for you all to come out to grow
a video live too because
it should be an experience and and then
there's even things last i think partly
this has helped from being a part of not
just church because just because you're
part of church doesn't mean you know
some of these things but being a part of
churches that are thoughtful about like
greeters
like people welcoming people i call them
generators and it's just thinking about
what we learned in church is also too
from parking lot to platform
you might walk in and like you don't
know where to go
signage
okay
and then you get in and not only that
like if you're volunteers your
volunteers are like
you you walk up you're like is this is
this youth man's event and they're like
yeah they open the door
can i can i go through here i guess
like you don't want that volunteer like
you don't want that person you you want
to be thinking about the fact that like
we're grateful you're here
hospitality you know good energy
the right people on the front lines
and those types of things can make or
break an event of course you want the
content to be good you want
i mean all the way down to don't let
people do widescreen
slides
squished into 4-3 or vice versa
i mean
i'm about to have a mental breakdown
because i see this stuff i see people
who call themselves professionals like
they got resolution right their audio
sucks there's feedback
i mean i remember friends i have been to
events i've been to a lot of events
i have been to high level events there
was an event that brendon burchard was
speaking at it's pretty pretty big dude
and i
said you do you think this funny hit
like this
this is on the internet uh
and the entire time there's like a
thousand people at this event i'm
speaking at this event
it's in southern california
brendan burchard is speaking they've
spared no expense except for on the avl
team
he's out of
focus the camera
is back focused
so if you could imagine right
he is blurry and the uh and the camera's
autofocus is tracking to the back wall
the entire session
actually when it would cut to the side
angle he'd be nice and crispy
so i'm watching this and i'm like are
you kidding
i'm like the recording's ruined first of
all we're in a huge room and there's
imag he's bl he's literally blurry who's
the cameraman who's the cameraman's boss
who's the event promoter i actually know
all these people so i'm sharing no names
or events
will be disclosed
and
i even addressed it like because i know
the person and i was like hey uh you
know i don't know what happened i heads
up for future sessions
um you know you might not want like
these all-star speakers to be blurry
when it comes to your videos
of them it would be better for the
guests and for the recording that's
where i because i think about the
recordings i want the audio and video to
be crispy for the reuse
you're throwing an event so that would
be the other thing youth man is think
about
like as much as it's a lot to think
about so delegate and get as much help
as possible like think about how you can
use all the content you're getting from
your event for your youtube channel but
only if it's actually in focus hopefully
and if like
you know and too often i see people who
claim to be professionals
uh will will like
after the event you'll be like so hey
how'd the session go and they go oh um
the audio was like not on i'm like
what do you mean the audio wasn't on
like you have one job dude like what you
talk
you were
like it actually should be unacceptable
it's amazing how much people get away
like i don't know else like because
you're also all you can do is be
incredibly sad like the meme music plays
it's like
hello darkness my own friend
like
why am i still here
just to suffer
like because once the audio is gone it's
gone or once it's staticky the entire
time and i was like was nobody manning
there is an event
where the virtual
experience streaming
the gain
going to the virtual feed
was so low and i heard somebody telling
me they're like i was listening to the
virtual fee oh they were driving in for
in person and they had the virtual
ticket
they go i had to turn my hyundai
speakers
i had to turn it up to a hundred
all the hiss noise you know because like
the audio floor was so loud i had to
turn it up i'd do a hundred
and i could barely hear the speakers
speaking
but then once the guy fixed it i got
blown out of my car because the gain
levels were set wrong
youth man this is not a lightning round
but i have a few tips for your event
please
take care of the details make sure the
recordings are great and uh and when i
went back when by the way when i talked
to that person about brenner burchard
being out of focus
you know what he said to me he goes no
he wasn't
and i was like
what
what do you mean like have you ever
talked to somebody that's delusional
you're like
it's either in focus or out of focus
like you can it was out of focus like no
i don't i don't think it was
what
what it it was i mean i it's fine like
maybe we could fix it for the future and
there's forgiveness but not if we can't
admit
and so anyways
that's all i have for you
well that was quite the journey of
emotions as we talk through some
different events
um
i can tell that this is shawn's pet
peeve well yeah i mean
and it's funny too because now i guess
i'm like the ceo of our company but this
is my roots like
freelance videography
you know event production our church had
a tv show
i i managed my church's youtube channel
and so
training the video guys
and one of my biggest things too though
is a lack of humility
and so if you make a mistake admit it
um if if anything's less than
world-class admit you're trying to grow
uh but but but there's a weird level of
pride amongst audio and video
professionals
because sometimes i just go i'm like
listen it just doesn't sound good like
can we make the feedback stop and they
kind of look at you this is a last story
so i'll be at these events these are all
true stories
and i look back at like the avl team
and there's you know there's a list
there's a whole thing of uh
tables there's tables
because there's probably like what
there's a lighting board
it's the soundboard
maybe there's a soundboard for the
online
you know
there's maybe that pro presenter where
they're control controlling what's on
the screen you know if you've if you've
seen some of these it could it could be
pretty robust
and so
i'm at an event in l.a
and and at these tables right
there's like 10 people back there
okay
so then you're sitting there listening
to the speakers
and and you're like
why there's all they're static
this mics are cutting in and out
the speakers are also kind of blown out
like the gains jacked honestly the avo
was even wrong for the room like like
they didn't have the right tools for the
room people pay good money too like this
is like this like almost thousand dollar
tickets so it's kind of crazy
but then i'll look back and i'll be like
what are these 10 people doing like
just sitting there like
well i mean how can you endure the shame
of
of just sitting there
anyways
and so
if anything
and then i'll i'll be like hey you know
we can maybe there's there's some audio
video lighting problems and someone will
go uh
yeah i mean it's it's fine i okay
i mean it's not fine
but uh okay we'll we'll keep it going
sound man pay attention
uh union it could be it that actually
that's actually a solid point in here in
vegas that's sometimes true like you
have to actually because of union labor
you have to
like literally have someone stand by the
plug to plug it in depending on like
what it is so
anyways okay you've got a question for
question marks before and after if
you've enjoyed tales of botched audio
video and lighting um
then uh
then let me know you could tell i am
passionate about events done well youth
man i i am in general and uh and really
audio video and lighting has a chance to
really it should just disappear that's
the goal of it right is you just want to
be like i'm focused
i'm not distracted static mics cutting
out you just want to remove distractions
you want you want there to be a
relationship between the people in the
seats and the communicator you don't
want also
okay i got one more for you
how hard is it for people to get
slides and clickers to work i have a
million stories
like how hard is it to get
give the speaker a confidence monitor
how hard is it to give the speaker a
clock but
there's too many stories where you'll
ever see you've probably all seen this
like you've been to an event where the
person will be like
it's not working
and they'll go hey can you advance my
slide hey can you advance my slide
hey can you advance my slide
hey can you advance
like if you're in that situation
you've made a lot of poor decisions up
into that point
if you're just finding out that your
clicker doesn't work that the wi-fi in
the room is wrong that the thing isn't
wrong in the room
you you waited too long
to get it right
so i okay
i'll let it go i don't know if i can i
can let it go the gaming mom's seen it
it's too common
like click oh and then because think
about it it ruins the experience on
stage because then the person's like oh
shoot oh my oh maybe my slides don't
work okay or maybe the clicker doesn't
work that's just it's stopping the flow
it's wasting time
oh oops uh
oh shoot oh can you advance my slide
it's all that's all friction you want to
remove and so if you can remove friction
from your events that's that's
ultimately uh the goal
um
yeah for real that's your staff get good
people get world-class people and i'm
empathetic man avr avl i've that's what
i've learned it's incredibly hard
um
it's it's a true like being world class
at audio video and lighting and events
understanding atmospheres at a high
level and energy and event flow is a
real real skill and so um all right
let's let's rapid fire a few more
questions for you
um
i saw someone also ask they said
they're having trouble getting the book
free if you haven't already downloaded
the
uh book
it you will have to actually get it so
so if i click the link to buy the book
it's not free yeah well if you don't
already have it it's not free to be
clear
so
here's here's how it works
a lot of people have already downloaded
youtube secrets audiobook and all you
have to do is remove it from your
library
in your audible app
and then re-download it and you'll get
the updated version for free
um
if you also go to tubesecretsaudio.com
and you've never downloaded audible
before
you can get a free you can get it free
now i'm assuming you already have
audible
and so
in that case you will need to use a
credit or just pay whatever the price is
i think it's like nine bucks and you can
get the updated version
so i hope that clarifies uh that for you
and um
and check that out smash like if you're
enjoying your saturday
and uh
here we go all right do you think a
disability focused channel might do
better
as a personality based channel generally
i'm struggling with direction please
help
so aaron
um
i think you have a couple things to
consider i think
that
you know who is your channel for and
what problem does it solve
so if your channel
is focused on maybe helping somebody
cope with live with solve
we have a vra student that um
has had very successful youtube channel
about helping people travel with
disabilities
so
um this gentleman's in a wheelchair
and
it's think about how clear that is
it's his situation that he's overcoming
and he's helping people travel with
disabilities so it's clarity of the
channel
i would say that
if you were to tack on disability to
like something else
um
like
a disability pokemon channel
like around pokemon cards the two things
would not need to be combined like you
could potentially just do a pokemon
channel
so just to break down your options like
is it
when you say disability focused is it is
the target audience someone with a
particular disability
um
is the channel 4 for everybody watching
this is a huge question you should
answer and a lot of times we start with
us in the spotlight versus actually who
the channel is for
whether it's personality based or not
then is also up to you
because it doesn't have to be
personality based
any of us watching this has the chance
to do what would be considered a
faceless channel which could be
um
voice-overs and b-roll it could be
educational there's a lot of like
history explained channels for example
they explain history
they show old photos from books images
off the internet clips fair use or like
creative commons clips
so there's
aaron i think it's understanding that
there's so many different ingredients
you have
there are channels that succeed teaching
just off uh you just see their hands
drawing
you just see slides or digital art being
drawn out and they're never on camera
so you have a million kind of different
ways you could go
my question would be
what do you want to do
you know who is it you want to help
um
what
who do you help and what problem do you
solve
um and then you know finally erin it's
like you could just brainstorm maybe
five to ten that's what we recommend
uh
i don't know if i have my three p's
around
uh
you could brainstorm five to ten
passions and pop channel possibilities
and then potentially pick one
that overlaps with
what you think might also be most
successful
so
i think that some of us haven't spent
the time to brainstorm okay i could do a
personality channel talking about my
experience having a disability that's
one option but like let's try to come up
with seven others even if that's what
you end up going with you go also
okay i could create a
a show review channel
where i do recaps of shows
by the way
a lot of those you know you can use the
shows for fair use so if you just
watched
ozark season four you can you can go to
youtube all the time and people recap
season three and there's like still
shots and they're like everything you
need to know to get ready for season
four so you might go i could create
like a streaming tv
uh review slash recap slash easter egg
channel there's a second idea and then
you're like cause i i love and i geek
out about shows okay you're like i'm
also a comic book enthusiast i have a
huge collection of comics i could
actually create
so
i think getting a little bit outside of
the box aaron i know that i might have
just given you like 100 more ideas than
you kind of had but i think that all of
us could kind of benefit from taking a
step back and thinking about okay and
here's the three p's it's like what am i
passionate about then also what am i
proficient at what can i talk about for
hours what do i know a lot about what do
i have experience in what could i help
others do what have i overcome in my
life that i could help others overcome
in their life what do other people
acknowledge me as knowing about when
other people ask me questions what do
they ask me about
you might have a friend that always
knows how to get the good deals and
always knows how to do couponing or
something
if someone always asks you hey where's
the best deals maybe you should start a
deal channel or a coupon review review
channel or or couponing you know dollar
store because
we get so close to even our own skills
or experience what do other people
acknowledge you know a lot about dude
you know everything about the wu-tang
clan oh my gosh you know everything
about classic rock those can be signs
and signals
to what you're also proficient at and
then finally you go profitable so at the
intersection of passion proficiency and
profit profit would then be okay how big
is the market for this maybe
a classic rock vinyl review channel of
reviewing old albums you have
may or may not scale to what you want
financially and growth wise as
diving into pokemon which is something
you're deeply passionate about or some
kind of niche game or something
so
uh
that's
i hope that helps smash like if you're
getting value on a saturday as we are
hanging out here
um and
um
let me okay here we actually go
lightning round
uh okay
lightning round
all right i don't have any new questions
all right here we go
you've got a question put four question
marks before and after your question
randy asks my best performing video is
on the spiritual realm
i should double down on that video i
think absolutely if you ever identify a
winner
a breakout video a a video outperforming
other videos
then think about how to make a part two
part three think about how you can turn
it into a series
and then realize and randy something to
check is is it getting real-time views
in your youtube analytics
if it is
then
you have the opportunity when a second
one comes out
so real-time views means every two days
people are watching it even if it was
released weeks ago or months ago or
years ago great so this video continues
to be watched
so then when you release part two
the chance of the correlation on youtube
of this one also being recommended or
even autoplayed after the other one or
being suggested along with the other one
is very high when you release part two
and something else related to it
furthermore if this one's getting
real-time views
it's also probably growing and getting
you subscribers
so when you're subscribers
the chance of this part two getting
recommended on your homepage
on their homepage with browse features
or getting recommended
uh or them even wanting to watch it
that's another good point they click
subscribe because something about the
spiritual realm was in the title so when
you release like
more truths about the spiritual realm
they're like i love that they'll
probably watch that so there's actually
like algorithmic correlation but then
there's also just the human relationship
correlation
that if all of a sudden we did a video
that like
it was on adobe premiere and lots of
people liked it if we do another video
on adobe premiere the people that are
subscribed
will be like oh sweet i want to watch
more stuff on premiere a good example
that's the canon m50 in think media
history like
anything we did on the canon m50 would
continue to do well for a couple factors
lots of subscribers had one or purchased
one
but even beyond that
it was a very it's it's like an all-time
camera canon m50 is like the jordan ones
of cameras
like it's a legendary camera
so it has such wide appeal
that
whenever we put out m50 videos they
would outperform other types of content
and if you're watching this that's a
great question to ask yourself friend
success leaves clues make part twos
what videos in your library have done
exceptionally well that you can make a
part two or a follow-up to
that can be very beneficial to you
friends
this is exciting if you're just joining
um
the second edition of youtube secrets is
out
and it's can it's been kind of a weird
release the audio in a way kind of
leaked but i'm excited
uh because if you already have a copy of
youtube secrets you can just remove it
from your audible account
redownload it and you'll get this for
free
now if you've never got the audio book
before yes you either have to buy a
credit
or use one of your credits to get the
book totally worth your time five hours
and 29 minutes of updated content brand
new for a new decade
one rewritten chapter one overhauled
chapter the whole book is redone with
case studies and examples and and
tweaked and polished
two brand new chapters rewritten
appendix with a whole list of really
awesome resources um and it will
absolutely be worth your time i think it
will help you not just get into the
right mindset for dominating youtube in
the next decade but it'll give you some
fresh tactics that you'll be grateful
for um
if you've never downloaded audible you
can use your one free audible credit at
tubesecretsaudio.com to also get it free
or you may have to again spend the nine
dollars to get it um and you can just
purchase a credit uh as well
and uh
if you
whether first edition or second edition
want to review the book i'd love to hook
you up with a free course
um our course crush collabs was recorded
a few years back it's now been sunset
but but the um content in it is amazing
this is a 97 dollar
value
it's all about collaborations how do you
reach out and get people to collaborate
with you how do you reach out to bigger
channels and get them to pay attention
to you we give you a couple emails that
you can copy and paste
how do you reach out
for people to be interviewed on your
show
and i believe it's at least four
training videos um
you're gonna love this again hook you up
with it entirely just uh for free
if you leave a review of youtube secrets
um my dream scenario is that you say
talk about the the
second edition be like dang second
edition is fire and uh i'm not trying to
put words in your mouth if you hate it
just leave it on honest review
but
i think you'll like it and so uh just if
you leave a review
then email
support sean cannell.com with the
subject line book review
and then just post a link or a
screenshot of your review
and we'll get this to you it'll be
during business hours if you happen to
do this on the weekend which is when i'm
recording this and going live
then um
hold your horses it'll be there soon we
will send you that course we will honor
you
and uh hook you up with that in in
celebration of the leak
in celebration of the
discombobulated release of youtube
secret second edition the kindle is like
not updated it looks like the physical
book is but here's what we know for sure
the audiobook is out ahead of schedule
um and uh we are super super fired up
for it in fact um claire's got a great
question
what are the main updates
um
the main updates are
a whole lot of new data about the crater
economy
and so here's the new chapters it does
look actually like the physical i just
discovered this that the physical book
looks like it's good to go uh new
updates about the crater economy
uh in the preface and the introduction
so this has been rewritten here you go
so the preface and the introduction how
how far can i go sweet i actually so it
looks like you can get the
uh the physical book because if you
click preview this is all the new
chapters so it's about
80 new pages because the first one is
197 pages the new one's like 270 pages
so um we've the seven seas of youtube
success are
um
slightly tweaked but they're the same
because they're it's an unbreakable
framework that's the first that's part
one
um the introduction preface is over
overhauled the perfect video recipe
though claire this is my favorite
chapter the perfect video recipe
updated for exactly what's working on
youtube
tied for
for second place with social media the
good the bad and the ugly we rewrote the
whole social media chapter
and the big idea there is actually how
dangerous social media is to your
youtube success
you gotta find out what i mean by that
um there's tips but like i actually
think social media is one of your
biggest enemies if it's stealing your
time it's not the best use of your
energy while you're trying to grow your
channel and how even sharing your
youtube content on youtube uh how
sharing your youtube videos on social
media can actually be sideways energy in
a lot of cases so you'll love that
chapter discoverability was rewritten
because there's just new rules to
discoverability that's kind of the vra
stuff and i mean if you're in vra like
we don't even come close to what you
have access to you've got
yeah right masters and we're dropping
the 16 video formats in there and all
that kind of stuff but like you'll
you'll get a concise explanation of
what's working for
kind of ranking
um and then the new youtube features
this chapter 15 is brand new where it's
all about shorts community tab stories
youtube live youtube kids app um and
just some new things and then the
appendix is all updated and so yeah
we're pretty pumped i mean
um
worth worth checking out and especially
if you've got
the uh
oh no
you got you got the classic now
unavailable first edition arriving last
week
and uh
and
if you
have the audible though claire you ha
you can just download the audible so
just remove it from your library
and then update it and the second
edition of the audible will you could
get it right down let me know if that
works for you you should be good so
um
and uh yeah yeah yeah yeah check it out
check it out
all right
answering your questions today my name
is sean cannell rhymes with youtube
channel um
what do you think about buying views or
subscribers to grow faster i do not
recommend it so
um it's
it's only going to mess your channel up
if if only be neutral because um
if you buy subscribers like they're
either just bots and so they'll be
inactive
but
there's a ratio to the amount of
subscribers you have when you release a
new video and how your subscribers
interact with that video
so
the quote-unquote only reason to buy
views or subscribers would be for vanity
numbers just so someone could do a drive
by your channel be like oh wow there's a
good amount of views and subscribers but
what is that that's just vanity it's
just pure optics doesn't make any
difference into actual sustainable
youtube growth
that's the best case scenario the worst
case scenario is you get some
subscribers that now are not active
they're not clicking on your new videos
therefore youtube is not getting the
right signals the algorithm is not being
triggered properly
and it's in a way confusing the
algorithm
and so i would just avoid it with a 24
yard stick
yep
all right
looking at some of the questions coming
in here
here we go i have an idea for a reaction
channel is it worth it for adsense can
you make videos uh money from these
yeah i mean let me know what your idea
is
reaction could be reacting to anything
you could react to
ted talks
and
if you built up
a good audience
probably professionals like let's say
you're a speaker coach or like a
professional speaker which you probably
aren't but let's for just the sake of
the conversation about reaction videos
so
this is an incredible channel idea i
don't know if this exists
and obviously it would be assuming
you're great at
breaking down public speakers so watch
this any public speaker coaches
you're welcome
so you create a reaction channel
you react to great speakers ted talks
any talks that are online so you have
unlimited people to react to you could
react to
presidents you could react to
famous people like tony robbins and you
react to these different videos but you
break down tips and insights
and observations
about powerful public speaking
the adsense on that channel would
probably be incredibly high because it'd
be being watched by other speakers and
professionals
that would want to be interested in that
kind of information
so just by saying it's reaction shadow
now what i assume you mean
is like
literally the react brand which maybe
reacts to
funny stuff meme stuff and
i think here's the big question when it
comes to how much you can make for
adsense
who's the audience
younger audiences people with less
buying power
non-us
uh audiences
have lowered cpms
flip side uh
personal finance older audiences
the medical field the financial field
the crypto field the tech field have
higher cpms
the type of people watching it we get
incredibly high cpms on think media
because a lot of people
researching cameras wanting to buy
software buy cameras watch the content
so
who is the reaction channel for that's
the biggest question
and
here's the final thing
you can win either way
if you go lower cpm
it's kind of like very entertainment
it's for the masses
but it might not be the most if you will
quality of audience and that quality
means again
that's why a personal finance
channel gets paid so well is because the
quality of the audience is people who
want to like
invest their money so they want to sign
up for publix.public.com
or like
td ameritrade and those types of brand
the brands that want to add what brands
want to advertise on the videos there's
your question
what type of do brands want to does just
mountain dew want to advertise on the
the videos to hit the masses with their
latest code red drink
or does
wealth factory
want to advertise on your videos to get
in front of an audience that might
invest thousands of dollars with them
those brands are going to want to pay
for the types of videos they're
advertising on
and so
you can win either way
if you go the
wider less affluent
potentially audience type of content you
need more views
so you just gotta blow your channel up
millions and millions of views
and you might find an intersection your
cpm might be great and you're getting
millions of views great you're winning
the cool thing is if you pick the right
niche that's a more profitable niche
then you're good on the other side
of you don't need a ton of views
you have a higher cpm higher rpm
and
you're off to the races for earning
uh if you will a lot more money does
that make sense hit like if you're
getting value right now
cpm right now is 8.50
what's your rpm uh speak english with
this guy is it around four bucks or 350
or something like that
it's not too bad it's pretty good uh
think media right now
um
our uh our cpm
it's
27.67
rpm's 11 15
as of this moment and of course it
always kind of fluctuates some of that
stuff is it is somewhat external meaning
i mean there's external factors ad rates
go up ad rates go down
the december ad rates are usually
through the roof or around november
because of holiday shopping so there's
certain summer maybe brands are
advertising less a lot of different
things
um
claire i had an amazing affiliate deal
for personal finance but it's no longer
legal in australia be careful with money
talk yeah there's definitely money
regulations financial service providers
we talk about like have to be careful
with what advice they give or what
financial software's they recommend and
stuff so definitely do your due
diligence if you're in the personal
finance space do your due diligence
regardless
uh what are the two free ways to get to
the book uh michael great question
so
the two free ways to get
the book
are
number one if you already have it
which you probably don't that's why
you're asking the question
but if if you're watching this and
you're like oh yeah i already i
downloaded the audio uh youtube secrets
um
audiobook
a year ago
a week ago
you just actually go into your library
you hit the three dots
you say remove from device
on audible
next to the book
and then re-download it
and it'll be the new edition
and you'll just instantly be upgraded no
other charge no nothing extra you'll be
instantly upgraded to the new book
if
you um the second way
is if you go to
tubesecretsaudio.com and you've never
downloaded audible before or you don't
have an audible account
you can use they'll give you one free
credit and you can use it for the book
those are the only two free ways to get
it the other way though is you're like
shoot i already have audible maybe you
get one credit a month you either could
buy and add a credit to your library
you also can buy through audible just
the book i think it's nine dollars for
the audiobook
um
or you can
uh use that free credit or use one of
your credits
and so that's how you get it and by the
way
second edition or first avert because
this is this is like a fresh stream
this like leaked out i checked it i was
like oh shoot whatever it's saturday
afternoon
and i was like might as well
turn it into something let's talk about
it and let people know how they can kind
of get a head start grab the book free
and also if you want to leave a review
i'll send you our crush collabs course
for free all about how to do
collaborations get high-level guests
uh to be interviewed on your show
it's a 97 youtube course
just review the book
on audible or anywhere on amazon
honest review
and then just email us at support
seance.com and in the subject line
make sure to write book review in the
subject line
and then send us a link or screenshot to
your review that actually makes it
publicly on amazon
some reviews don't don't make it
publicly because a lot of times if you
go half-hearted with them
you're like book good
and so amazon might not post it so it's
like and it usually takes like 24 48
hours for the review to uh publish and
be patient we will honor you with that
course if you do that
um
and
uh
we'll do it during business hours we'll
make sure you get that course
uh christianity explain asks when's the
ebook going to be updated i don't know
that's i don't know what's happening all
i know is i got on here to tell you
about the audiobook
the kindle clearly here
is not ready yet
and so
yeah you can actually tell
that it's the old book
here
and so i don't know i'm sorry
uh that's but that's the point of
today's stream is that the audiobook is
updated and apparently we just
discovered together a few minutes ago
that uh the physical book the paperback
looks like it is updated as well
and so uh hey here for it we're learning
together and so i i i'm gonna have to
i'll be back on you know sometime next
week
i can verify that this is the second
edition because the chapters here's how
you know when you preview the physical
book you see that there's chapter 8 the
perfect video recipe chapter 15 new
youtube features the original book only
has 13 chapters um so you see uh that
new content there so it looks like the
physical book
is available on amazon
and
life is interesting so we're out here
uh mobile freelancer how often is your
online course updated well if anybody
here is from vrafam i'm also streaming
this in the the uh
a couple of our facebook groups
is uh
we have been releasing it's it's updated
quarterly just released a whole new
batch of 25 videos and what's called vra
masters
and um
it's updated quite often plus we have a
private facebook group where we
are going live
weekly with the tip of the week and then
we also have the monthly vra show and
we're answering questions and doing that
kind of stuff in there so it is a very
active
um community
and uh i would love to show you inside
actually
because i'm very excited about this new
um
uh
vra what's called vra masters and man
it's i mean i would think so that it's
great but
so you're going to get in here what
you're going to get is an introduction
to the 7r system 10 commandments of
youtube
um
and then you go through those first
six modules which this shouldn't take
you that long
it's not meant to i know you're busy you
got stuff to do you want to start
getting results in on youtube but then
eventually you can pop in here to vra
masters
and so
in here we're re-going through what's
called the 7r system
and all of these
have been updated these are updated a
month and a half ago or something like
that so this all brand new content
uh
my favorite video outline for
educational content the next piece a
quick transition to the next strategic
video how to improve the content of your
videos
and some of this new stuff in here
perfect video recipe is in here 16
surefire video ideas for standing out in
a crowded niche and earning passive
income and growing from zero to 100 000
subscribers quick
start going through all these
and so um
yeah we take it really serious i mean
this is like my life's work and
of course you always have our think
media satisfaction guarantee so you can
have the person peace of mind when
joining the program
um for you know 30 days to try it out
but but you i think you're going to love
it so
motivation health and wellness says vra
masters is great yeah that's the new
stuff
and um
and oh hey appreciate it inverted popes
bought the physical book thank you so
much after you read it um
if you leave a review email us a picture
of your review to support seancanal.com
and i'll send you my crush collabs
online course just as a thank you
i would love to hear specifically uh how
you feel about the second edition
um and so definitely check it out
um
my friends just got the update
on audible there you go it works so if
you already have the book
you can get the update for free there's
the dream right there the fit cosplayer
just just discovered it
yep you just remove it from your library
download it again and boom it's the
second edition no extra charge coming at
you
four years after the release of the
original youtube secrets
we got you covered with a fresh
overhaul of the book for a fresh decade
this next decade's gonna be the best
deck hit on youtube um the future is
bright and this is a good guide for you
to help you along the journey
yes there's tactics and strategies in
there um but
uh there's also the mindset man getting
a getting an unstoppable mindset
keeping your mental toughness strong
you know staying focused
mindset's a big piece of this whole
thing it's the whole psychology piece
question is
success leaves clues is that my quote
that is not my quote i don't know whose
quote that is that is an old quote
let's look it up success leaves clues
uh
tony robbins said success leaves clues
but it's not a tony robbins quote either
i think it's a jim rohn quote
and so
yeah jim rohn is is a classic kind of
leadership personal development looks
like someone wrote a book called success
leaves clues looks like multiple people
have written a book called success leads
clues so
you know
there you go
vra is like a youtube university i think
i just paid in full as of april 22.
that's amazing yeah you know as of the
time of recording which we're in we're
making some major changes to it but as
of the time of recording this video i'm
going live right now but
um eventually vra is going to be like
netflix meaning
there's no such there's not going to be
a lifetime membership because we do keep
updating it we keep it current
um we update it we add to it therefore
there's obviously an energy and a cost
to that it's not like an online course i
recorded five years ago and it's just
they're static therefore
it's not always going to be lifetime
access the era we're living in right now
it is so
uh la
dayosa um
did a payment plan and now that it's
paid off you're in there's no extra fees
no extra charges like literally you have
access to not just vra but the updates
the group the whole deal so if you're on
the fence about joining vra or you've
been in our community and you've been
checking things out like
it's this is the best era to to be in
uh before and so
um
you gotta just press record is my quote
punch perfectionism
in the face
is half stolen
from my friend john acuff
so
john akov has a great book that says
punch fear in the face so i think i say
uh i say punch
fear i see it came out one day when i
was like listen you got to just punch
fear in the face and punch perfectionism
in the face and press record and so
given credit where credit's due
great book called start uh punch fear in
the face escape average and do work that
matters from your boy john a cuff i'm
out here giving credit to whatever
quotes i can remember
um
and
so uh
start punch fear in the face
hey just got the audible edition great
great great just got the audio book
awesome hey appreciate it
uh enjoy let me know what you think
about it
and uh super grateful
all right listen friends um
my name is sean cannell i appreciate you
hanging out with me for a saturday if
you're just joining and you want to hear
all the details about the leaked
uh
the most
the most
unprofessional release
of the second edition possible that's
what i can say that we've achieved the
most
sketchiest release the audiobook came
out
the kindle's not out the physical book
appears to just have been already during
this stream so
um why we may not get an award for the
best book launch second edition
because who knows what's happening what
we can say for sure
is that the second edition of youtube
secrets
is out on audible
and if you already have it you actually
can update
it for free which is pretty cool
if you don't have it
well you don't get it for free
unless you don't have audible and they
actually do hook you up with a free book
tubesecretsaudio.com to check out all
the details about that
i want to thank you for being a part of
our community whether you're part of the
vra fam or inner circle whether you are
a part of our think media podcast
channel whether we just met whether
we've known each other for months years
i just want to say i'm grateful for you
i respect you that you're focused on
your dreams your goals your hustle your
youtube channel that you want something
for your family for your future that
you're putting in the work that you're
punching fear in the face that you press
and record that you're getting
uncomfortable that you're stressing
yourself that you're learning new skills
and i'm here to help
i want to help you win on youtube myself
and the think media team and um
thanks again for uh being here today on
this stream or on the replay if you
didn't know growth video live is just a
couple weeks away i'm going to end with
a video today
uh but thanks again for hanging out and
i will talk to you in a future video
have you ever thought about using social
media and youtube to market and build
your business online you know right now
youtube has over 2.3 billion active
users that's billions of potential
customers all on one single platform but
how do you reach them you've probably
been seeing other successful business
owners marketing their services
expanding their businesses and building
their personal brands all using youtube
and social media but you haven't been
able to figure it out for your business
and you know you need to take advantage
of this opportunity but you feel
overwhelmed with everything else you
have to manage you just feel like you
don't have the time for this so how can
you realistically start using video to
grow your business well we'll show you
exactly how at grow with video live
2022 conference go to
growwithvideolive.com or click the link
in this post or in the description to
secure your limited time discounted
ticket during this two-day event you'll
learn exactly how to grow and monetize
your business from experts with real
results you're going to learn directly
from proven industry experts who have
built reliable and successful online
businesses like gary vaynerchuk patrick
bett david shaleen johnson pat flynn
vanessa lau
and more you'll meet hundreds of other
creative entrepreneurs just like you and
connect with leading brands in our
industry join us in person in las vegas
or virtually from anywhere in the world
secure your ticket at
growethvideolive.com and take the fast
track to dominating the next decade with
video go to
growthvideolive.com or click the link in
this post or in the description to
secure your limited time